today I'm gonna show you how to add a  persistent disk to your Linux VM open  the Google developer console and go to  the VM instances screen click the  instance scroll down to the additional  disk section click Edit now click add  item select the disk create new disk now  give it a name select the type choose  blank disk specify the size and click  create now click Save now SSH into your  machine get the name of the disk by  using the LS block command now make a  new directory to mount your disk now we  can use the safe format and mount tool  to mount the disk specify the disk name  and the name of the directory we just  created and hit enter in a few minutes  the disk is formatted and mounted we can  use the LS block command again to see  the disk is correctly mounted